all right Samuel leaves you hope you are
good and today I wanted to do a quick
video I'm here in my office I've seen a
good some good property deals in
Manchester and I'm gonna talk about do
you do them yourself or do you send
someone to view now as much as I'd like
to stay in the office here with my
beautiful pregnant wife say hi Amanda
and my good friends mr. Eliot Spencer
and Elliott we've been through a lot
by five years old you know thought about
being still likes me and tiny Tavakoli
and ten is responsible for the one who
found the house so it's sourcing machine
so the question is folks who's going to
view the house is it going to be me is
it going to be Elliott up or is it gonna
be Tania or is it gonna be Amanda Leeds
what guys he's gonna do it oh yeah don't
pretend you're busy
you're going to Manchester oh come on
babe
I just want to stay here and read all my
all my books I mean jeez there's a lot
of books there not that I'm egotistical
or anything right there
okay the house is good I think it's
gonna have to be me that music now we've
got a friend called Chiron he literally
just finds deals and sells the buyer the
Internet of wine he's like is he's
bragging well how much money is he made
in this month about Holograms
and he hasn't left his house you know
I'm gonna break that you've got to do
whatever it takes sometimes you gotta
jump in the car and view so right let's
go
while Amanda's getting ready I'm just
gonna go say goodbye to some of the
other chamber so we know she is Paul he
they're fantastic Accounts Manager say
hi Paul Hey
and where's everybody else Max is
obviously unfortunately this is our
project manager and MDA perished but
Chris are you free for me to give you a
call I'm going to be asking some
questions while I'm there see this guy's
the man yeah I'll do that buddy thank
you so much thank you so you better
secrecy the airport Samuel Lea tosses a
beautiful day right here we go let's do
this okay so a little bit of frustrating
news we arrived in Manchester and
there's no one in at the property all
I've got a feeling that the vendor has
either sold it to somebody else or I
just don't know what so currently we're
driving around feeling pretty frustrated
and the plan is that we're going to book
a night here and we're just gonna search
and try and find a deal because I don't
want to leave Manchester empty-handed so
we've got 24 hours or less - following
the deal in Manchester so I'll keep you
posted on here we get on here at
Manchester United having a great time
[Music]
okay so still searching we're now ten
hours in frame that we'll find something
very soon that this could have a very
bad ending we'll find out
[Music]
so what just happened there I tell you
what didn't happen we didn't find the
house so we had Tanya deal sorcerer
spend hours negotiating and finding a
deal we had a project manager and
builder with his face time putting time
aside to look around it with me line
research I and my wife drove all the way
to Manchester to go zip which is a four
hour round trip and we didn't even get
in so what are the lessons from this or
lesson number one if you are someone
that searches for properties yourself
whether to buy them yourself or to pass
them on to somebody else it's a lot of
work you need to get builders involved
check through the property you need
sources to do the negotiations you need
to actually drive to places and view the
properties and if you're somebody that
pays sources to go and find properties
remember it is a lot of work for them so
if you're paying two three four five
thousand pounds tap someone find your
deals just be grateful
I remember the work that goes in well
though it was a little bit of a wasted
trip and we didn't end up with Dale I
guess it's just a reminder to myself and
to my wife and hopefully to you -
sometimes discipline your disappointment
as well as celebrating your success and
at least you got to see the team and
meet the project managers and Tanya and
Elliot and all some of the guys and see
our officers next time I'm gonna make
sure that we actually get in the house
and I'm gonna show you the figures I'm
going to show you the return on
investment I'm going to show you me
negotiating and hopefully we'll have
some completely different lessons and
it'll be a little bit more productive
land this week so if you'd like to see
me inside houses and you'd like to have
a tour and get to see exactly what I
look for how I find these types of
houses then subscribe below right now
and I'll see you next Monday at 7 p.m.
[Music]